where do we begin people are now just
about arriving back to university
perhaps
we have people who are maybe even
venturing into a new career post-covid
or
looking to become increasingly
competitive in a job market
they want to be able to consume retain
deploy information and learning and
comprehension and all this stuff
where do we even begin yeah
that's a good question i'd say probably
the main
principle that everything else hinges on
is that learning is supposed to be
effortful
it's supposed to be hard um and it's
it's so it's sort of like the analogy i
sometimes use for my students
is it's like when you're going to the
gym if you're lifting weights that you
can easily lift
you're not actually going to make any
gains it's just going to be a total
waste of time
but it's when you start doing that
progressive overload when you start
lifting weights that are that are at the
limit of what you're able to do
that gives your muscles the stimulus for
growth and then you know assuming you
eat right and you sleep well
then you're gonna get more hench and
you're gonna you're gonna be able to
lift more weight
and it's sort of somewhat equivalent for
learning that the harder it feels to
learn something
the more likely that information is to
stick and
this is very counterintuitive right
because
still to this day despite all of the
decades of research that have been done
about this that show that when learning
is effortful it's
better despite all of that evidence most
teachers uh still focus on trying to
make the content as convenient as
possible for their students
like very well-meaning teachers who want
to sort of categorize things into nice
syllabuses and create a nice
presentation and give them mnemonics and
essentially take all of the difficulty
out of studying for the student
essentially give them this packaged up
thing that they just have to learn
but in doing so the thing that they're
packaging up that the student just has
to learn it actually makes it a lot
harder for them to learn because the
student then
is not putting in any of the effort
themselves and so they have to start
finding weird ways to put effort into it
so that is probably principle number one
that all of the rest of the kind of
learning theory is based on
don't expect it to be easy and almost
lean into the discomfort a little bit
that if you are finding something
challenging to learn that that's a
signal that
it it's doing the work yeah exactly and
it's it's one of those things where
like i feel like there are very few
domains in life where
conventional wisdom is directly opposite
to what actually works
but certainly when it comes to studying
and learning conventional wisdom is that
we feel like we're stupid if if what we
have to learn is hard if we're
struggling through school or if we're
struggling to understand a concept we
think oh i must be dumb i must not be
doing this right
but in fact it's the exact opposite like
if you're
finding something hard it's a lot more
likely to stick because your brain is
having to work harder
you're operating at you're at the limit
of your i don't know your muscles
potential and then
that's the stimulus for growth and then
that's the stimulus for those
connections to form
so that it becomes slightly easier the
next time around what
else do most people get wrong about
learning
uh so a few things though there have
been some really cool studies about this
where
um because uh essentially college and
university students are a great
crop of people to do studies on because
you can pay them like three pounds and
they'll happily kind of sign up to do
anything
so there's been this whole swath of
studies about learning and studying and
memorization done on
college and union university students um
the other things that really make a
difference are
and this is probably you know apart from
the fact that learning needs to be
effortful this is
the single thing that makes the biggest
difference in people's results
for learning anything at all and that is
that
we learn by testing ourselves we don't
learn by reading stuff
and this is again it seems is is
counterintuitive because
when you tell people that they they
should test themselves and stuff
they'll say oh well i i have to learn it
first and then i can revise it and then
i'll test myself for the exam
and there's a really good book called
make it stick which is all about the
science of successful learning
and the authors basically say right up
front in in the introduction that look
if you're a student or any kind of
learner and you're not happy with the
way your results are going
chances are you're just not testing
yourself enough there's evidence that
shows that if you test yourself even
before you start
learning something that's going to
improve your learning if you test
yourself immediately after you learn
something that's going to improve your
learning
if the only thing you do after reading
something is just test yourself once
that is better than reading the same
thing four times
or writing a summary of it or creating a
mind map on it all you have to do is
just test yourself
and again this is so this is so country
intuitive
um we kind of think of in we we kind of
think of studying and learning
as if it's a process of putting
information into our brains but in fact
it is the opposite it's the process of
getting information out of our brains
and in
trying to retrieve stuff that is what's
forming the connections
whereas when we're just reading things
or rereading things or summarizing
things
with the book open we're falling into
that trap of thinking that
familiarity is the same thing as
understanding um and you've probably
seen this i certainly give this a lot
where i've read something enough times
where i think oh yeah obviously i know
this
but then if you ask me you know can you
actually explain it in your own words
without looking at the book
i'd be like oh okay uh maybe not and
again
there's yeah and there is some evidence
as well that
the the emotional component of it is
identical across
across both of these domains so for
example if you were to read something
that you've come across before
and you read through it and you think oh
yeah i recognize this it feels really
good because you think oh yeah i know
this stuff i know what's going on
it's exactly the same feeling as if you
try and recall something completely from
memory
and you get it right and you think oh
that's cool and so because we're so used
to
rereading stuff and reviewing our notes
and we have this topic of
revising as if revising like revision
like going over stuff again is going to
help
it feels good it feels productive but as
all the studies show and as everyone
who's tried this in real life shows
rereading stuff doesn't actually help
you learn it testing yourself on stuff
does help you learn it it's familiarity
masquerading as comprehension
exactly yeah that's exactly what it is i
had a
i had peter c brown on the show he was
like episode 19
two and a half years ago so anyone
that's interested in this and wants to
dig into
make it stick the book is really
accessible super good
read um and a nice primer for that is
it's like back in the teens please
please ignore everything about my
hosting ability and my sound quality but
peter's pete's fantastic on it um and
from that
the one sentence summary of make it
stick
is memorization comes from repeated
recall
not repeated exposure oh
that's a good phrase i need to start
stealing that that's fine man
you can note it down at 145 words per
minute on your on your mechanical
keyboard
everybody doesn't make too much noise
though on the recording that's what i
worry about what i'm doing
you considered a silenced keyboard yeah
occasionally i switched to my apple
magic keyboard which is a little bit
more quiet
if i'm doing like a live stream i'm
having to switch windows on the fly
because
that's a bit it's a bit obnoxious yeah
it is um okay
so we know that we need to lean into the
discomfort we also know that
um just continuing to read i mean
everyone knows everyone that's listening
has been that person
or knows that person who's like the
flash card addict
who's got everything laid out in a
million color coded
written and this that any other but
doesn't ever actually end up doing the
testing and what you're saying is that
we need to focus on the recall we need
to focus on the testing those are two
nice principles to start us off
where do we go next um i'd say next
the third principle that i was talking
about is one that's called spaced
repetition and this is again something
that peter brown talks about in in the
book
the idea of space repetition is um
we've all had this experience where you
learn something and then
or you think you've understood a topic
and you come back to it like a day or a
week later
and it's completely gone and again when
we when when this happens to us
if we're students we often think oh i
must be dumb i must be thick because i'm
not remembering this thing
and we'll look at the students around us
and we'll say oh but tom over there
from singapore you know he seems to
memorize things as soon as he reads them
uh but what tom from singapore is
actually doing is that he's not
memorizing things the instantly reads
them there's no such thing as a
photographic memory
uh what he's doing is that he's just
revising he's
he's repeating the the topic more than
once
and i don't know when i don't know how
this came into the sort of mainstream
where people think that
you should just be able to recall
something after coming across it once
uh it would be completely ridiculous in
any other domain of life like if you're
learning a song on the piano like
obviously you have to practice it more
than once to get it right if you're
trying to improve your tennis or squash
swing
obviously you have to practice more than
once but we think for some reason at
least
everyone on your university felt this
way that oh if i don't if i don't get it
first time i must be an idiot
and the idea of space repetition is that
it combats the forgetting curve
so back in the 1800s there was this dude
called ebbinghaus
who did a really weird experiment on
himself whereby he made himself memorize
a bunch of completely nonsense words
like completely made up words
uh not even the meaning just to see how
much he could brute force into his
memory
and he plotted out how long it took him
to forget each of these words as he
memorized them
and he found that it was like one of
those exponential decay half-lifey
graphs if anyone's familiar with those
whereby
you lose the majority of it in the
initial period and then the forgettings
kind of slows down so this is the
forgetting curve
and the idea is that if we repeat the
the subject by testing ourselves on it
and then by looking it up if we if we
got it wrong that
takes us back up to 100 memory uh but
crucially
the more we do that the slower this
curve decays
and so for example something like the
capital of francis paris
you've come across that fact enough
times in your life through various means
when you were younger
that you're never really going to forget
it and
that's because accidentally you've had
this space repetition thing applied to
it
whereas if someone told you the capital
of i don't know some random country is
some random city
right now you would forget it unless you
came across that fact again and again
and again and when you come across it
enough times over a long period of time
it goes into your long-term memory and
then you'll know and then you're never
going to forget it
so the idea behind space repetition is
that initially when we learn something
we then want to repeat the testing of it
fairly quickly maybe a day or a few days
later
and then once we've done that we want to
space it out a bit more so maybe a week
later
and then maybe a month later and then
maybe six months later
and so that's the spaced repetition
aspect of it and if we do that
we kind of get our forgetting curve to
be quite shallow and hopefully this
stuff goes into a long-term memory
does that work for all types of learning
i can imagine your background as a med
student i know that we'll
get into it soon i'm sure about anki
which is one of the most
popular space repetition softwares out
there um
that's a lot of kind of rote root very
much brute force memorization yeah
what about if i'm trying to do something
that's a little bit more fluffy
sort of philosophical concepts or um
literature comprehension stuff like that
in theory this should work for
everything
um at least so in in in make at stake
again referencing that book they talk
about a load of domains in which this
this sort of stuff applies it isn't just
for students trying to memorize
biochemical pathways for medical school
it is sort of hockey players competing
in tournaments it's business people
working in like
in the corporate world in all of these
different aspects of life where people
have done studies
you see this pattern of testing being
super important and spacing also being
super important
there's another book called uh range by
david epstein where he talks about
this basically in those exact terms he
says testing spacing and interleaving
are like the three sort of primary
things for
learning any skill whether whether it's
like knowledge for
a university subject or whether it's
like tennis or golf or anything like
that
how generalists thrive in a specialized
world also
also a past modern wisdom guest just
after that came out so if you want to
get on david x
epstein go back modern wisdom i think he
was around about maybe in the sort of
late 70s something like that
um so this is this is what i've done
every episode up until now
ali has just been a prelude to this one
and this is
a [ __ ] pinnacle right here um so
we've got
the testing the recall we've got the
fact that we need to lean into it um and
we've got the fact
that we need to do space repetition are
we on any more principles or should we
start to move into some
uh more stress strategic stuff now yeah
so i suppose the
the final principle is one that epstein
talks about which is interleaving
uh and interleaving is the idea that um
we kind of want to be operating uh
in in sort of our area our zone of
discomfort
so the example he gives in uh the
example they given make it stick i think
is looking at hockey coaches
and the way they found that this works
best is
you kind of train people and drill a
particular exercise
but just as your players are on the
verge of getting it and really leaning
into it
at that point you switch completely and
do a different exercise
and as soon as they're on the verge of
kind of getting the hang of that you
switch completely and do another
exercise
and the idea behind this is that it's a
bit annoying for the players because
they're not experiencing that uh you
know that mastery sensation that oh yeah
i know what i'm doing i'm the dawn
uh but when when you have that feeling
you you're not really learning anymore
uh and so the idea of interleaving is
that you want to be doing lots of
different things within a learning
session or within a study session
um and so for example again this
isn't how traditional schooling is
designed if you're having like a maths
lesson you would do
i don't know trigonometry and pythagoras
theorem and syncostan
and you would do it in like a very
specific order
and when you're doing exercises you
would kind of learn something and then
you'll spend the rest of the lesson
doing exercises about that thing that
you learned
where really the only thing that's
changing is just the numbers and the
concept is the same
whereas what the studies show is that if
you have a
if you add a little bit more variety so
you kind of make them do a little bit of
something a little bit of something else
a little bit of something else
the brain is never quite allowed to be
comfortable and therefore we're
maximizing our learning
uh and minimizing the time we have to
take to learn it how do you ensure
that you reach a particular threshold
and you don't
always keep selling yourself short so
that you don't get any comprehension
with anything
yeah i think that's that's where the
balancing act is because
whatever you're studying there is a
level of uh
a level of time you have to put in to
really engage with the material to kind
of really get the hang of it
and that's that's the tricky part the
thing that i
the thing that i do is that as soon as i
start feeling that feeling of
oh okay i'm quite enjoying this at that
point i switch tasks
so the interleaving and the discomfort
uh the the interleaving
is the it's the tool
with which you force the discomfort into
the learning process almost
yes if the learning process itself isn't
just it isn't uncomfortable enough where
you're actually
the limit of your thing anyway so for
example if i'm doing a completely new
like a brand new topic and i'm really
struggling to understand it i won't
bother doing the interleaving because
it's hard enough
but as soon as i'm at the point where
okay i understand cardiology i
understand how atrial fibrillation
works then i'm like okay let's let's add
in some hematology to the mixture just
just um spice things up and make it a
bit more interesting for my brain
you